it was just this helpless feeling of not
being able to do anything as a parent
all you want to do
is take it away and make it better i
cried non-stop for like four days it's
heartbreaking because we're then we're
faced with the with the real possibility
that that we could lose our daughter
lola rose had hours to live
her liver was failing
she was put into an induced coma i
didn't want to walk through those doors
i didn't want to see her like that i did
because she's my little girl and i
wasn't going to let her do that alone
whether she knew i was there or not i
was going to be there but seeing it for
the first time was just horrendous
lola needed a donor
allen was told he was a match
and after lying side by side in surgery
for more than seven hours
half of his liver was transplanted into
his daughter
it just tears your heart out you know
just seeing your little girl in a coma
literally
days away from dying you know it's and
you know that she's deteriorating all
the time and there's nothing that you
can do about this
lola's sudden onset hepatitis was
triggered by an adenovirus infection but
it's a common infection that usually
causes flu-like symptoms
not acute liver failure
we still have to report new cases dr
tasos gramaticopolis is one of the
country's leading pediatric liver
specialists
and here at king's college hospital
where lola is being treated they're
seeing a rise in cases
the
most recent lockdown in the pandemic has
probably played a part in this because
children have not been exposed to common
pathogens to common infections like they
would do had we all been out and about
venturing in the community so i think
that probably plays a part on this
current surge
but also there are a lot of other
factors that we're looking very
carefully with other agencies in the
country trying to establish exactly
what's going on
that's one plausible explanation
another being explored
is a mutating virus
sudden onset hepatitis is rare in
children so young but the world health
organization is quite concerned about
this recent spike in numbers cases have
been identified in europe in the united
states and more than a hundred here in
the uk in the last three months alone
lola's is one of the cases being
investigated by the uk hsa
so we are worried seeing eight
transplants in the first three months of
this year is out of sync of what we
would normally see
that's
more than we would see normally in an
average year in this age group
there'll be parents who are watching
this who are obviously very concerned
what can you say to them to allay their
fears
these cases are rare and unusual um but
it is important that we uh go out inform
people and ensure that they understand
how to prevent spread like other
respiratory viruses
[Music]
jane and alan say it's a miracle no
larose is still alive
the science that saved her is now
looking for answers to prevent other
children from suffering the same ordeal
ashish joshi sky news
in south east london
you